warren buffett once told the story of
his closest friend from columbia
business school
he said the guy was incredibly smart
incredibly hard working really strong
ethics great character
and
they kind of were in a similar spot as
they graduated but the outcome of their
lives was dramatically different based
on a single decision
the
friend of his went to the steel business
and he said worked you know very hard
and earned a modestly you know modestly
good living um while
warren went and started his first
private partnership and then what would
eventually become berkshire hathaway
and he said this final quote which has
always struck
me or struck me then and stuck with me
since which is what i learned was
it's not as important how hard you row
but what boat you are in
and so
in the video that i'm about to show you
this was a presentation that i was given
for a keynote
and they asked me to talk about what
they called level seven entrepreneurship
so once you kind of they have like
levels one through six that they were
talking about level seven is kind of
rising above the businesses and using
your businesses as or seeing your
businesses almost as products that
increase your you know personal net
worth etc i took that to mean how do we
assess and appraise opportunity itself
this is one of my one of my favorite
presentations i've ever given um and i
hope that you get value from it mosey
nation for those guys who don't know me
by the way my name is oxford mosey i own
acquisition.com
it's a portfolio of companies that does
about 85 million a year and i have
nothing to sell you all right so i make
these videos just because i think a lot
of people are broke and i know it should
be one of them and hopefully some of the
lessons that i've learned along the way
uh can help you so uh buckle up and
enjoy
how's everybody going
awesome
sweet
uh so i am a level seven entrepreneur
category five hurricane uh level ten
fire breather top secret security
clearance holder
uh it was kind of weird to
hear the context for the talk today
because
i don't really feel like a level seven
entrepreneur um
just
feel like somebody's taking a couple
steps forward and one toe after the
other so
let's rock and roll everybody good with
that
sweet it's acquisition.com that's our
fancy logo
awesome
you guys want to hear something totally
insane
uh oh i can see it here much better uh i
was able to take home more in a year
than the ceo of mcdonald's
ikea
ford
motorola
and yahoo
combined
as a kid in his 20s
which is equated to over
1.2 million per month in dividends for
nearly half a decade
and i haven't talked about it publicly
that much mostly because
didn't really care to we're at an
interesting point and ryan asked me to
to bring this up
where we've exited two companies this
year sold our house sold our car
and i'm kind of in a season right now of
consolidation and kind of distilling
down
what i like to call artifacts so just
frameworks that crystallize the
learnings
so that i can set forth for my next
chapter
with kind of a backpack full of lessons
and so i have way more frameworks than i
will be able to share with you today um
that book is the first of 10 books
that i'm writing on it that is really
just expounding on one framework
but i'm going to share with you four
today
that hopefully you get some good stuff
out of all right and no one was more
surprised than me
to hear those numbers
so
what's interesting is that me expressing
that fact
creates envy in some people anger and
others
skepticism in most and confusion in old
people
and hopefully inspires a select few
because you guys are who i'm making this
for
so
these are just a few level seven
observations i added in quickly this
morning uh because ryan asked me to talk
about a couple of these
some things that i've learned
one everyone wants you to do well just
not better than them
except that no one actually wants you to
be rich except for you
i really mean that
because if you're not fighting for you
no one else is
money only solves money problems and
then you are left with problems that
money can't solve
you don't arrive you just enter a new
club as the smallest member
the guy who
literally lives in the unit directly
above me in my building
took home 1 billion this year in income
not an exit
income
he owns outright 100 owner 3.8 billion a
year in sales 26 net margins
and last year he took home 920 million
the year before that he took him 850
million cool guy
so
i'm just poor
and
one of the last observations i'll say is
that this last year i would say we fully
exited the the org chart
and we're making pretty much the same
money that i just showed you
and uh it was wildly uh
boring
and like almost depressing and so i i
kind of have this thing that like let's
make active income cool again because i
think passive income is slightly
overrated because we all have this
desire we seek freedom
but what i really think we want is
options
and we want engaging activities because
we like imagine because all of us buy
back all of our time
and imagine you buy all of it back
and you're making
all the money
and you do
nothing
it's terrible
um and so i'm just sharing this with you
because that was my goal for such a long
time that when i kind of got there it's
it's not it's not fun like all i want to
do now is start something else because
i've got a lot of summers left right
so
might as well do something cool
all right so who wants to hear about
stuff that can shortcut your path to
material success so you can ponder the
purpose of achieving it to begin with
cool
awesome
all right so my name is alex for mosey
founder of ce and ceo of acquisition.com
and i have nothing to sell you any mosey
nation here anyone
a couple all right awesome
so uh except for this book which you can
get for 99 cents on amazon um pretty
cool this actually just released three
months ago almost 2000 reviews on amazon
so people seem to like it and uh total
side note for everybody who's a super
duper marketer here uh
i released the book with one post zero
funnels zero ads zero upsells
um
and so i think that
there's something to be said for
intention behind how you create your
business
um and people can feel why you're doing
things total tangent i was talking to a
buddy of mine who just sold his company
for 200 million
and he said you know what's interesting
is that when you talk to most people he
said 99 people were plugged into the
matrix and what he meant by that is that
they're operating from a place of lack
and a place of desire
to
get other people to give them money
right that's kind of where they operate
from he said when you exit the matrix
it's very rare but you'll see that when
you make things just for the sake of
making them like art
then they have they take on a whole
different form and this book was kind of
the first of the many things that i hope
to create from that same space
and so anyways i hope you enjoy it if
you do pick it up and hopefully i'll
prove to you some enough enough value
for 99 cents so
how i turned 1036
into 85 million a year in portfolio
revenue in five years using four
frameworks
and that is december 20th 2016.
so your life can change pretty quickly
all right so that was me when i started
i didn't have enough money
for rent so i slept there
skill those locations from it always
still hits me um mostly because i'm just
grateful you know for where we're at now
anyways um sorry scaled these locations
from zero to six um and three years off
cash flow which is pretty cool
um then i did 18 months of doing gym
turn around so it's kind of like gym
rescue or like bar rescue but gyms but
no gym owners want to get rescued so i
called it jim launch brilliant marketing
right there uh
and this is actually the first ad i ever
ran which is actually me just doing a
walk through of this hook this gym in
the hood
hood
um and i did 191 sign-ups in 19 days
just me selling one-on-one at 500 bucks
each i would show you but i don't think
we have enough time
but that ad if you ever want to check it
out it's on my youtube channel it's got
like 400 000 views um it's 90 seconds so
anyways from there we packaged the ip
for a better gym model because i had six
gyms and then i did all these
turnarounds
we scaled that to 2.4 million a month
which is a b2b business
then we started a supplement company
scaled that to 1.7 million a month
that's b to b to c and b to c
uh for those who don't know that means
business to business and business
consumer sorry and business to business
to consumer uh and then after that we
founded a software company which killed
a 1.6 million a month which was b2b2c
uh which we actually just sold two
months ago
and uh yeah that was cool
and then we co-founded uh a national
photography chain uh which now 14 months
later is doing 1.1 million a month so
and now we have acquisition.com so we
take interest in seven eight and multi
uh e-learning and local chains and we
grow them to exit so that's what we do
which is cool for me but what's in it
for you all right so here's my goal for
the presentation to help you get you
from where you are
using some of the lessons that i learned
the hard way and a few stories to make
them stick
uh to a level seven zillion entrepreneur
cool which is an entrepreneur who
contemplates the meaning of life because
they have no need for money
great
so if you've achieved if someone has
achieved success i'm going to use quotes
here
faster again quotes here than you
then they simply have been better
allocators of a single resource and it's
probably not the resource you think all
right so i want to base my presentation
today on a single premise which is
time allocation is the only thing that
matters if you master time you will
master material success not saying
you'll master happiness i'm just saying
you'll master material success
all right and so don't worry this is not
a time management presentation
this is a presentation on how to drag
your time horizon by the balls into the
present all right way faster than
everyone you desperately want to beat
i mean that
right like you can drag your time
horizon to the present if you learn how
to
think differently
all right so
from the outside what appears to be
speed is not lots of activity that is a
fallacy that most entrepreneurs believe
all right it is making the right
strategic decisions and making fewer
mistakes so if you see where it says
micro fast macro slow for the most part
when i look at entrepreneurs and i see
what they're doing that's what their
life looks like they go really fast and
then they change directions they go
really fast and they change directions
but i can tell you my neighbor who's
right above me has been doing the same
thing for 40 years
and it's micro slow
macro fast and the speed comes from not
having to take detours
if you consistently move forward over a
long enough period of time you go really
far
and so here's a level seven observation
for you
ninety percent of success can be boiled
down to consistently doing the obvious
thing for an uncommonly long period of
time without convincing yourself you're
smarter than you are
so
i like this quote from naval ravicon
it's loose i just remember from a book
or something
i only believe that one percent of
decisions matter the rest of them are
irrelevant the difficulty is
understanding which are the one percent
of the 99 of the ones that matter
and so what i want to give you some of
the frameworks that shape my one percent
decision so you can use them too all
right
so first off this is the premise money
is the denomination of time
every transaction we make is for some
percentage of our lives
our wealth is a measure of how little of
our lives we must trade for the things
that we desire
money is an iou from society for future
goods and services which is translated
as other people's time for value that we
provide
and so to somebody who has lots of money
they need to trade very little time by
percentage of their life to get the
lamborghini for somebody who has no
money they have to trade a very large
amount of time to get the same
lamborghini
it's a it's just a store of time
and so the key multiplier in time is
leverage
and the size of the opportunities that
we pursue aka the strategic decisions
are directly proportional the amount of
leverage that we can employ
rich dads and i think this is the
biggest difference in economic equality
tell their kids to pursue high leverage
opportunities
real estate funds acquisition business
ownership that's what they encourage
their kids to do because they've already
jumped through the levels and they know
what is there
most people don't succeed because of
ignorance not because of lack of
desire poor dads tell their kids to
pursue low leverage opportunities
forcing those kids to have to learn the
hard way like many of us did what
leverage actually is many times never
discovering what it is until it's too
late
example get a good job build a small
business and i'll clarify what that
means in a second etc
and so this is a
a good book you can probably get most of
the takings um just total side note i
think one of the most valuable things
you can do is just read billionaire
autobiographies because you get to see
how they think so he said uh and this
this this this hit me like a ton of
bricks he said it's harder to build a
small business
than a big business because level 10
town is only attracted to big
opportunities
it's harder
because you got to do it on your own
you got to do everything
if you chase the big things
it also makes it worth it because
small goals and big goals are equally
difficult you have to spend time to
achieve either of them so you might as
well make them big
like really like that like does that
make sense it's like that hits you
because it hits me
so with that being established
these are the four frameworks that i use
to apply leverage and have given me the
quote faster than normal quote material
success that many claim to desire
number one and i apply these frameworks
when we're looking at investing in
portfolio companies when we look at
ourselves and our own companies what
we're going to do to scale them and so
these are the four things i look at
number one scale the entrepreneur
number two scale the market
number three skill the deliverable
number four skill the business
now from a equation standpoint because
this is how all these things work
together
a level 10 entrepreneur
on a level one opportunity will still do
pretty well but not that great
opportunity is a function of two of
these things the market times the
scalability of the deliverable
if you've got a numb nuts on a level 10
opportunity they'll still make money
some of you guys know them
some of you guys are them
and then finally the business acumen is
to understand how the actual enterprise
itself has to scale
all right so let's start with the first
one
you are not making as much as you want
because you are not as good as you think
you are
fact
if someone in your marketplace dare i
say competitor is making more than you
it is because they are better than you
at the game
do not throw stones at them throw stones
at your ego instead
admit deficiencies and learn their
strengths it will be the only way to
beat them
so
if we can admit the deficiency then at
least we can create space to learn so
how do we get better
look at the entrepreneurs the first and
most important thing that we do when
we're looking at trying to get into a
business and so every business is
bottlenecked by the entrepreneur in one
of three ways and so if you're the
entrepreneur this is you
number one
you'll either lack a skill
number two you will lack a character
trait number three
you will lack a belief
so imagine a ladder
and you can think of this as you've got
traits you've got beliefs and you've got
skills
if any side
of that ladder is missing no matter how
develop the other components you will be
limited to the lowest rung
it's just like this is this is the
theory of constraints right just
visualized
so fun
activity i will tell you the problem and
you tell me whether it was a skill
deficiency a trait deficiency or a
belief deficiency
a long time ago in a galaxy far away i
had 10 businesses
i also had no money
i had six gyms
i had a turnaround business four gyms
i had a chiropractor agency i had a
dental agency
yeah i think that's it it's a six plus
yeah right nine or ten a lot plenty
my lovely wife laila who is not my wife
at the time said uh
you need to pick something uh or you're
gonna you know
or i'm leaving and i was like oh man
that is a high stake
i should pick something
and so uh i ended up picking something
what do you think the issue was what was
my deficiency as an entrepreneur was it
a skill
gonna get hands for skill
hands for trait
hands for belief
interesting okay well this is my opinion
the lesson is niche slapping fallacy
which is the fallacy that
if i pursue all of them one of them will
work out
which is a fallacy it is false when in
reality all of them could have worked
out but none of them will work out if
you pursue them all
and so many of you probably have your
hand in two things you're like i'm not
really sure which one it is [ __ ] pick
pick
because the people you're competing
against who are beating you just have
one thing
and imagine right now for a moment that
one of those businesses disappeared
everything that you have
on that business just vanishes
how easy would it be to make the other
one win
so just do that
so the lesson was the niche lapping
fallacy what i lacked was focus and for
me i think focus is a character trait
so that was the trait deficiency
but i wasn't done yet i still had more
things that i was not successful because
of so this is me talking about my grand
plans too this is at my first location
by the way
this is how i was showing how i wanted
to build america's next gym
and so sorry it's really cute
um and so anyways i went to this
mastermind uh it was russell brunson's
inner circle this is five or six years
ago and i said here are my grand plans
i've got six locations i've got my next
four picked out
and i told them about how our model
worked and everything and he said
i think it's a terrible idea
and like my heart sank because i was
like i looked up to this guy so much
because i was like god i mean if i can
just get one thing from this guy
and he said
alex you have a level 10 skill set in a
level two opportunity
you shouldn't be running gyms you should
be teaching gyms what you do
and that's where it's like the big
frameworks that change your life
and that's what i'm trying to do with
this presentation for somebody in the
room is that it's the big strategic
decisions that make the big impacts in
our lives it's not the incremental gains
it's the rich dad who says why are you
even bothering with this this is not big
enough
you're never going to achieve scale
running a liquor store it's just not
going to happen
right
but you need someone like that from the
outside to get that perspective
and so this was what i got from russell
years ago
and so can anyone identify the deficit
that i was suffering at this point in my
career was it a skill or a belief
belief
and so this was actually my trajectory
of me as a multi-gym owner
i had lots of skills
i had
decent character traits i think
um but i didn't know that it was
possible i didn't know that that was
something that you could do and so i
switched from being a multi-gym owner to
a licensor
and so finally this is what a skill
deficiency looks like and i'll give you
one that i hear all the time in internet
marketing i'm sure ryan has heard this
as well
no good sales people exist
no one can sell like i can sell
my sales team is so inconsistent some
months they close a lot sometimes they
close a little i want to kill them and
sometimes i don't want to kill them
sound familiar anyone
isn't a problem it is a skilled
efficiency
you lack the skill of recruiting hiring
interviewing training and managing a
high performance sales team
that's all it is
and so it's not that this does not exist
it's that i do not have the skills to
conquer this problem
and so
here's a pro tip or a thought
is binaries versus continuums so if you
might check the box and say well i know
how to manage a sales team
the question is not whether or not you
know how to manage the sales team but
how well you can manage the sales team
it's not a binary it is a continuum and
as a fun thought all of these things
exist on a continuum your skills exist
on a continuum your traits exist on
continuum it's not whether you're honest
or not it's how honest are you
so the best way to learn is to phrase
your bottleneck or complaint into a
solvable question
my sales team is inconsistent how do i
learn to create consistency in sales
simple right
and skill i'm not going to get into how
learned skills but this is the
the quick quick bit comes from
repetition and feedback aka volume
the volume of work that you do
which is why i think we need to make
active income cool again all right so
i uh
just looked at my crm
this is years ago
and i was able to pull
the stats from my personal closing
because you have to say who closed
something in a crm for gyms
and over a three and a half year period
i had closed 4 000 sales in the crm
these are one-on-one sales
and so i often get the question alex you
seem so certain or
you're so good at these things
how do i shortcut that and the reality
is that most people don't have that
rocky cut scene of eating [ __ ] and
they're not willing to go through it and
maybe you are going through it right now
and so my promise to you is that your
work works on you more than you work on
it
you build your character through the
work that we do
we increase our capacity to do work
itself and so if you can think about the
work that you're doing is increasing
that trait rather than the output of the
work
then i think it will help a lot of
people get through some of the harder
times
it did for me
and so some of the things some of the
sayings that i have in my community are
do the boring work
and outwork yourself doubt because
conviction doesn't come from positive
affirmations in the mirror
it comes from having done something so
many [ __ ] times that you're bored of
it
because it's like well obviously this is
how you sell obviously this is how you
scale a sales team because you've done
it so many times and i was on a podcast
not that long ago for young male
entrepreneurs and the the guy was like
hey you know i really hear what you're
coming from you know i know you did your
all those years of eating [ __ ] that no
one talked about
and so for all the audience that just
wants to like shortcut all that
what's your advice
and i was like you'll never beat me
because you're not willing to do it
and so i think that the biggest
deficiency that people have is their
expectations
and so because we have these very lofty
expectations everyone's trying to become
a millionaire in 90 days when if i were
to get you to sign a contract this is i
promise you'll be a millionaire in five
years but you won't earn anything for
five years until you become a
millionaire would you be willing to sign
it most people say they would
but they don't live like they would
and i promise you that if you live like
you would you'll hit it
but everyone just starts over every 90
days thinking that this is going to be
the thing
when you could have just had that slow
gradient that will get you there
eventually so i'd rather get rich for
sure
than get rich quick
and so the best part about all this
stuff is that skills traits and beliefs
all compound and that is what yields
crazy outside returns seemingly
overnight
and so
this is actually one of my favorite
parts of presentation just side note um
so let me give you an example of someone
who's good at math let's say you're
anybody here good at math born good at
math cool
so
i wanted to make this into into
individual slides so pretend each of
these lines are not shown until i say
them cool great
all right so let's say you're good at
math all right
cool not very monetizable all right
moving along let's say you're like you
know what i'm going to start bookkeeping
i want to learn how to you know keep
books
like okay cool now you have something
you can at least monetize and then you
say you know i'm gonna get an accounting
degree i'm learning how to do accounting
okay now this is something that's really
becoming a career you can feed your
family etc and then you say you know
what i'm starting to get in a tax
strategy then all of a sudden you learn
how you can you can help businesses
avoid tax drag as my lawyer says
and then you learn into you you learn
about insurance because you're like oh
this is cool too and it has really cool
ramifications also for tax but also for
some some investment stuff okay that's
cool and then you learn how to negotiate
deal structure ah now we're can you
start
seeing how the person changes as we're
talking about adding these skills to the
repertoire first you're talking about a
bookkeeper then an account then maybe a
controller now we're talking to cfo
and then
you have an amazing mastery of capital
markets
now you're a rainmaker
and so the thing is is that for this
little example it's one plus one plus
one plus one plus one sub one uh equals
a zillion right the point is that these
skills stack on top of each other and
create asymmetrical returns to all of
these skills that came before it
and as a fun example this was my actual
skill stack so first i learned how to
get in shape and work out
then i learned about nutrition which was
a whole nother thing
then i learned how to sell
so i started making a little bit of
money
then i learned how to oops market
locally so i started getting leads and i
already knew how to sell so then it was
like boom it was like a huge magnifier
on the other three skills i had before
that then i learned how to operate so
then i scaled to six locations
and then i learned how to scale sales
team so i had six people selling at all
those locations
and then
i learned how to market b2b nationally
and because i already knew how to scale
sales teams i'd been doing it for years
i knew how to do high volume
transactions i knew how to operate a big
business because i had
40 employees when i was 25.
so i had all these other things but as
soon as i had that belief that i had a
different vehicle that i could pursue it
in
we went from
zero
to 28 million a year
in 20 months
pretty cool
and so as a different example here's
jay-z's little skill stack
he learned how to uh
man see if i if i could have like
revealed it later it would have been
funnier but it's okay so
he had rhythm right he had a natural
skill or procrivility proclivity towards
rhythm all right then he learned how to
write lyrics and rhymes right then he
learned how to sell got people his cds
and get on stage right then he learned
how to promote himself
then he learned how to create a label
and then he learned how to recruit other
talent
and then you got beyonce right
and so the thing is is this making sense
and so
what might be valuable for you because i
think i've just been through an
introspective period is to think what is
my skill stack
and what are my deficiencies
and which of these deficiencies are
keeping me from what i want
and why am i not working on them
cool
so does every human here see how you can
become an entrepreneur through higher
leverage
through auditing and improving your
skills traits and beliefs yes
all right awesome check the box
so framework number two scale the market
so
i went to this mastermind all the people
in this little picture actually do 600
million dollars a year in revenue
which is pretty cool
and i had this really interesting
experience because i was one of the
smaller guys in the room in terms of
revenue uh at the time i think we were
doing 35 or 40 million somewhere in
there um and i was like why are these
guys making more money than me
because i was like i was like i don't
think these guys are smarter than me i
was like why
why are they making more than me
and so i was left with one thing right
and the answer was
they picked better markets
so when i looked at what all of these
guys were doing almost all of them were
mass-market they were selling something
that was expensive and they could target
the world and i was like huh they have
better markets than me and i was running
up into this this cap of my market right
around 30 or 40 million
and so here's a quick little framework
for you guys in terms of how to pick
your market because many times i said
that the equation here right
entrepreneur level 10 times market level
10
times delivery vehicle which i'll get to
in a second level 10 times business
acumen is what makes builds fortunes all
right so the quick answer was you have
to select the avatar that you can
provide the most value to the number one
question i get which which avatar should
i pursue the one you can help the most
simple
the medium answer is pick an avatar so
that you can productize your service and
provide that value with low operational
drag and that's why you pick one so you
can do the same thing over and over
again and get better and better and
better at it so you don't have to spend
as much resources to do the same level
of value which is create margins which
is what you can take home and spend on
lamborghinis cool
so this is my live speech answer
if you had one thing to get with your
hot dog stand
so i give everybody here a hot dog stand
and you have one competitive advantage
what would you want
would you want the best location
would you want the best ingredients
would you want the best tasting hot dogs
best marketing
what would you want
ah someone's read the book
[Music]
and this is actually a store of a
marketing professor who says this at the
beginning of every marketing thing
of course
they said what you want is a starving
crowd because no matter how shitty your
location is if when the football game
lets out and everyone's drunk at two
o'clock in the afternoon and you're the
only hot dog stand there and you've got
a starving crowd coming to you you can
sell out your hot dogs they can be dog
[ __ ] you're going to sell them right
they probably won't even care right
and so these are the four attributes
that i look for in a market that i want
to pursue
one
is pain right they must not want but
desperately need what i have to sell
them number two
they must be able to afford what i want
to sell them a friend of mine
had a business where he could help
people improve resumes to get more jobs
problem
they didn't got no money
right
can couldn't afford his services
the third is tactical is you want them
to be easy to target right it's amazing
if you want to find you know vegan
grandmas or whatever but if you can't
tactically target them it's one of those
things that i would just cross out and
be like sounds hard there's going to be
other hard things i'd rather not add one
to my list
and then finally growing a good friend
of mine um had a had an ad platform that
he sold to newspapers
and tries he might it was growing and
then his growth slowed and then it
started to shrink and he could not
figure out what it was he was like i
need new hooks and he knew offers and he
couldn't figure out he's a smart dude
and i was like hey lloyd i was like you
think it might be because you're selling
the newspapers
shrinking 25 per year compounding
right it's just the big obvious thing so
if you're going to go into business you
might as well do something with the
tailwind if you got the choice might as
well pick something that's growing right
i know this stuff sounds simple but some
of you guys are in shrinking markets so
i'm like why
rich dad poor dad right just make the
smarter decision
so i'm going to skip through this stuff
i hit it most of it
and i'll just i'll say this one little
story that i like a lot
warren buffett talked about
one of his the smartest classmate and
his closest friend from columbia
and he said this guy was brilliant he
was hard working really high character
dude he's like and i went to go build my
partnership the berkshire hathaway well
eventually would become
and he went into the steel business he
said
we did dramatically different even
though we both had the same skills and
level of skill and he said and that's
what taught me that it was far more
important what boat you are in rather
than how hard you row
and i think a lot of you guys are in row
boats
and you need a bigger opportunity
vehicle
and so the old vc saying is
great entrepreneur poor market
market wins
poor entrepreneur great market market
wins
that's why when people are looking at
investing they're like what markets do i
want exposure to
why don't i just ride the tailwind
so
now once you've selected a better market
you're going to want to scale right
right
so
um i'll skip the story but sure [ __ ] it
short story uh
i had an agency owner came up to me he's
like alex i've scaled my agency
everything's saturated i can't get any
more clients should i enter another
market guys doing 2 million bucks a year
spending 50 000 a month on ads
and i was like you're right
chiropractors are completely tapped out
the
10 billion a year that goes to
chiropractors and total revenue your
rinka dink 2 million dollar marketing
agency has completely saturated
whatever shall i do great question
friend these are the five ways you can
scale your market so let's just use
salon owners as an example let's say
that's your your avatar of who you're
going after whatever so there's your
ideal market
weight number one you can go up market
all right so that would be going to
multi location owners chains franchises
etc
number two you go down market go to hair
stylist people who will eventually
become your avatar in time
number three you can go to an adjacent
market so something that's very similar
in terms of the core desires of the
customers that you're serving right so
might be lashes and nails
you can go broader which just means
going even wider right lashes nails
skid crews med spas you know salons
massage etc right
or you can go deeper in your existing
market which
if i did tell you that is usually my
favorite which is buy competitors and go
figure out new platforms add outbound to
your system increase your ad budget it's
just doing more of the thing that you're
already doing which if you ever get
anything common themes for me is
do the boring work
if something's working do more of it
usually works better
great
so does everyone see how you can enter a
better market and then scale it
framework number two
boom check it all right
number three
this framework that i'm about to share
with you is the opportunity lens through
which i look at all opportunities that i
want to pursue all right it perfectly
tracks my progression this is actually
pretty cool
so
i got this i borrowed part of this from
naval ravicon um who's really brilliant
you can follow him on twitter um but
there's four
four c's to leverage all right i said
the whole premise of this presentation
is leverage so entrepreneur check that
box mark it check that box now scaling
the deliverable so i'm looking at a
company i want to make the deliverable
more scalable increase the profit margin
here's how you think about it
so the first level of leverage is labor
so back in the day this is the only kind
of leverage that's how the pyramids were
built that's how ancient royalty had
they just had bodies
right the problem with bodies nowadays
is that you need permission to do things
right and so you have to ask people to
do things or pay them to do things
otherwise they won't do them it's such a
bummer right we'd make so much more
money if we didn't have to do that
second our second level of leverage and
this is a higher level of leverage is
capital this is what the next generation
of billionaires and fortunes were built
off of buffett monger etc once again
they used other people's money so
permission is required unfortunately
can't just take the money um but you can
still make a lot of money just
leveraging capital right and at this
point in time it was leveraging capital
times labor
the third of this is code
the difference here is that this is
permissionless if you write software you
don't need to ask permission to
duplicate it it just will continue to
deplete over and over again right at no
cost so if you look at the mailchimp
founders it was code that is what
created their billions
and then finally you've got
content
or media right that's how joe rogan can
sell his
podcast for 100 million dollars what's
his product
media it costs zero cost of replication
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna bring this
home in a second i promise you'll like
where we're going all right and then
you'll notice that above the top line
zero permission is required for either
of those things and that is where the
new fortunes are being built and right
now if you look at that pyramid and
you're like i'm not on that pyramid
you should get on that pyramid because
that's where all the fortunes are
and if you look at the very top here
these are guys that use all four
bezos zach dorsey they've got labor
working for them they've got capital
working for them they've got code
working for them and they have content
and media working for them all of them
with permissionless leverage
interesting
cool
we call that a leveraged forebanger
it was funnier on the plane when i added
that slide
so i was only able to see this trend
after i had made these jumps so my goal
is by showing you this trajectory you
can do it proactively all right so each
opportunity jump that i'm about to show
you 10x to my income
at first i was an employee i was a
management consultant i was someone
else's labor i was making four figures a
month
then i became a trainer i was my own
labor i'm my own master right so i
became self-employed i jumped to five
figures a month
then i became a gym owner and then i got
to finally use labor as leverage i got
to use other people's time right and
then i went to six figures a month
then
and this is a big pivot
i went from
leveraging labor
to leveraging labor and media
which is i started licensing right i
started licensing something that has no
cost to replicate all right and that's
when we started making a million dollars
a month i'm talking income not revenue
here by the way
next level is eight figures a month and
this is where i think we're headed we'll
do about 85 ish million this year we'll
see how the quarter ends um
and this is because now i added capital
into this mix now i can buy things
right so it gives me more leverage to
expand what i'm already doing and so
this is what i think will get me to
eight figures a month i'll let you know
when i get there
um and then finally nine figures a month
is doing the whole stack right do i know
what i'm going to do there not yet but
i got summers
okay
so mind you this is a framework it's a
tool all models have limits but it has
served me well and thinking how to
expand is that helping you
sweet
so you guys want a really cool bonus
framework that i've been thinking about
for a long time i have six minutes left
so you won't get it okay
i can go all right [ __ ] it
well
pretend you never uh
that all right okay
so um
cool you said yes to this fantastic okay
so this is low leverage this actually
took me like you know these little
things take like five minutes each to
the little lines and [ __ ] anyways
uh so here's framework number three
scaling and deliverable so this is the
delivery cube so when i look at a
business that i'm looking to buy into or
improve et cetera
these are six different types of
questions that i ask which is number one
can i do this thing in a one-on-one
setting a small group setting or a
one-to-many setting and can i change the
price accordingly
number two
is this a do it yourself a done with you
or a done-for-you solution can i move
along that spectrum in either direction
in a way that might optimize my outcome
for better profits
number three what level of support do i
want to offer this is a little bit more
service space but hopefully it'll help
some of you um
do i want to do
tech support do i want to do chat
support do you want to do email support
do you want to do phone support we want
to do zoom call support what type of
support do i want to provide
do i want to probably different levels
at different income levels or different
payment levels
something to consider
consumption for if i'm licensing
material do i want it to be written do i
want it to be live like this do i want
it to be audio only do i want it to be
video how am i going to package the
information
number five speed and convenience if
someone has help for me is it 24 7
is it nine to five
do they have a response time of under a
minute do they have a response time of
two days
right these are all variables that you
can use to increase or decrease the
value
or margin that you are using to deliver
and then finally this is probably my
favorite of the six boxes if you can
have a favorite on a framework about
delivery
one is i want you to imagine the value
that you provide right now and the price
you charge for it okay
now i want you to 10x that price
now i want you to think about what you
would deliver if that were actually your
price
how much more would you do
interesting thought process
blue sky do it on your own time but it's
a good thought experiment you should do
with your team
number two
think again about your your current
product
if you had to deliver more value than
you currently are
but for one-tenth the price
what else would you need to build that
would cost nothing to replicate
to provide the value
and number three
if i if i could have a favorite question
of my last framework of number box six
this would be it
if right now the gods of marketing ryan
dice gives the god voice and says you
can no longer get new customers from
marketing
and the only thing you have are your
existing customers
and the only way to get a new customer
is for those customers to bring them to
you
how different would your client
experience look
food to think on
the thing is that people think that word
of mouth is dead
that book right now if you just do the
math
is selling like 250 000 a month of books
off of word of mouth and no funnels
people can spread stuff faster than ever
before we're just not taking advantage
of it because we're too greedy and too
short-term thinking like if people
aren't referring your stuff fix the
stuff why bother promoting it people
don't want to talk about it
i don't know
time check for myself apparently i'm on
time
um
everything is for sale and this is uh
this is another quick framework i'll
give you for scaling delivery i have a
ton of these these are just two that i
wanted to bring up so these are the only
things you can ever sell because i've
been trying to think through what are
the base chunks based units of [ __ ] you
sell all right you got products you got
services you got access
you have media you have risk and you
have money only things you can sell and
i challenge you to think about something
else and if you do figure one out that
doesn't include these as base chunks
i'll add it all right because i've been
thinking a lot about this
and what's even cooler about this is
that each of these components have
physical and digital pieces so a
physical product would be a bag of you
know dog bones right a digital product
is what a lot of you guys sell like a
course right
a
physical service would be like a massage
a digital service might be marketing
physical access would be access to this
event or to a real estate building that
you rent every day so that you can have
shelter
digital access might be if there was a
virtual recording of this live
digital access
you have physical media like a billboard
digital media you guys should hopefully
know what that is you're here
you've got physical risk like your
building is being insured and you've got
digital risk like a cyber attack
and then you've got physical money and
everybody knows about cryptocurrency
this is kind of cool the different
things you can sell so here's the
challenge is can you think through how
you can add one of these other
components to your existing offer stack
without providing a lot of operational
drag but while also providing value all
right and so i got a couple i presented
this to a couple a smaller group
and they were like what about
experiences i was like experiences are
products plus service plus access
a business
is all of those things chunked together
titles like if i wanted to make you a
knight right what do you get you get
access
if i wanted to give you ip that is
access to products
so when you're thinking through this
like those are the base chunks that
build everything and so i think
sometimes when we can just boil it down
to what are the base units it can be
useful in thinking what else can i sell
or what can i transform my existing
things into that are more valuable and
so here's an easy thought this is one of
the more genius things that we did is
that
if you're an anybody here an ad agency
a couple people well i'll tell you what
we did is that we uh
we had the agency side and they were
like huh
what if we just find the winners
and then license the winners every
single month to everybody else who wants
to run their own ads
all margin
great idea
made us an extra million a month in
profit you should try it good
recommend
um
number two add an experience to
continuity right
or add physical products to digital
experiences right these are all
different ways you can mix and match
these things
time check return fantastic does
everyone see i can add leverage to your
deliverable from those two frameworks i
shared yes
say yes awesome all right
check the box number four scale the
business so we covered a lot today and
we feel like this a little bit all right
fantastic so i'll wrap this up by
showing you what we can focus on in each
revenue level in that we what we focus
on each
revenue level for our portfolio
businesses when we come in to scale them
all right
so these are my last five years of
revenue um from 2017 until now all right
if you notice that's what being stuck
looks like
i didn't know what to do
and so um anybody want to know what
happened there
yes cool i read this book
um which i recommend it's a good book
but there was one chapter in it that
completely
made everything click for me and so i
applied that book
because up to that point i intimately
understood what it took to get to you
know 35 40-ish million but i didn't know
how to get past it now i do and that's
what i'm gonna share with you all right
so
who here is zero to a million can we
leave egos at the door
okay cool
one product one avatar one channel
if you have multiple businesses and
you're under seven figures a year
stop
more businesses clearly aren't making
more money
one product one avatar one channel but i
thought i should have multiple
acquisition channels you don't even
[ __ ] make money yet so no one product
one avatar one channel the problem that
you're trying to solve here is that you
have no [ __ ] clue what you're doing
all right the objective is consistently
sell something to people actually want
that's the objective
that is why we talked about picking the
right market first
one to 10 million
the objective is to increase the
lifetime gross profit per customer i
don't like saying lifetime value because
no one knows what it means and it's
revenue for the most part i like to
think about what is my gross margin on
the things that i'm selling right
the problem is that most times when
you're at that million-ish you're not
making enough money take home and so the
problem is that you're not making enough
profit per customer to scale which is
what is required to go from one to one
million to ten million and so the
objective is to add higher leverage
deliverables so that you can make more
money hence why we went over the
deliverables make sense
awesome
10 to 50 million
what happens here is that your
consistency of delivery starts to drop
and so what you need to do is you
actually have to start professionalizing
the business this is where you actually
pay taxes and you know don't go to jail
and pay payroll and all that kind of
stuff right um and the problem is that
you've inconsistent delivery you have
poor tracking your crm issues are [ __ ]
and your finances are a mess all right
the solution is you have to hire a high
level experience you've already done
this before all right
so
that is where framework number four is
this is scaling the business this is
actual business acumen all right
and then finally framework x
uh and framework one is alive this
entire time because you have to become
the entrepreneur that is required
at each level sometimes your best is not
good enough because what is required is
more than your current best
and so i think rather than thinking like
i'm trying my best it's like well it's
clearly not working
so
why don't we just try fixing the problem
and ignoring your feelings
so
framework x attract talent all right and
this was the piece that i was missing is
that what happens is you have to grow
revenue streams innovation dies at this
level of business because one
entrepreneur can only do so much
right and so you need other stallions to
come in who can drive revenue
all right and so at this point the
business actually becomes a
conglomeration of many businesses so
think about it of having 10 ceos that
all run their own p ls that are actually
growing their own mini businesses within
the larger context of yours if you think
about amazon amazon isn't one business
it's a zillion businesses globe together
so as you scale it becomes more globbing
things together becomes more acquisition
etc
as a result of this all right so here's
the solution is you have to get new
talent incentivized to drive growth so
i'm going to skip this story
you guys want to hear a cool mental
model alex sharpens right here
so there's six external this is the
function is how i define them let me get
five and just yeah
so
one is lead gen
two
lead nurture three sails four customer
success five ascension six resell all
right these are the things that all of
you probably know how to do hopefully
right
this is how you scale
these are the six internal business
functions that mirror the external
everybody knows their cpcs their cpms
what percentage click-through rate their
speed to response hopefully
what percentage close rate you guys have
but i'll bet you if i ask you how many
applications do you get a month
what percentage of those applications do
you get to book a call
what percentage of interviews are you
are you transitioning into a full-time
role what does your onboarding look like
for a new employee what does that
training look like
how do we ascend those people what is
their career path is it clearly defined
for them with role a title and pay
and then finally
what's our retention on this
and i'll tell you the quick story for
why this is important
so
i had a team of right now we have a big
cold call team we have about 26 guys and
the lowest wrong on that is cold calling
so they call people who don't know and
so for those who are like our sales team
sucks like try calling people who don't
even know who you are and then get them
to buy a 40 000 thing so our sales team
is pretty good
so
we had this goal for two quarters my
sales director said we're gonna we're
gonna add another 10 bdrs and i said
great goal two quarters later we haven't
added 10 bdrs so third quarter in a row
i was like what's your goal he's like
i'm gonna add 10 bdrs and i was like i
feel like we've done this before
so
why haven't you added the 10 bdrs and uh
because this is where we're like okay
this many calls equals this much sales
blah blah blah right everyone's done
this
what do you think the bottleneck was and
i was like wait a second how many people
are you interviewing a week
five
from hr
i was like well five's not going to get
us there
because that was just replacing the
churn of the front line position and
just like you have turning customers you
have turned in employees especially at
the front line
and so when we discovered that the
actual limiting factor was hr
not running enough ads to get enough
interviews and changing the actual
process we had 10 hired in two weeks and
it took us three quarters to get there
and so
two weeks later now we have double the
applications that are coming in for our
business and i'll bet you that all of
you have one of these things you're one
amazing hire away from all the growth
you ever wanted
you just got to identify that that's
actually probably most of your
bottleneck
especially as you scale
cool
so does everyone have a clear idea what
they need to focus on to scale their
business at their current level
yes check box number four awesome so did
everyone get something they can take
away hopefully and drag their future by
the balls towards the present
if you enjoyed this stuff you can get
more frameworks like this for free at
acquisition.com that's a course there's
no opt-in you can just watch it it has
downloads and all that kind of stuff um
it's free there you go and if you like
this my book's 99 cents i have a youtube
thing that's free i have a gram thing
that's free obviously and if you're a
company that's e-learning or
brick-and-mortar chain looking to scale
we help companies that go from here to
here and beyond
and at acquisition.com we believe you
should only have to get rich once thank
you
[Applause]
you